Dans certaines parties du monde,
la situation est devenue un inquiétant problème social.
En Asie, par exemple,
les médias rapportent que des patients désespérés
achètent des organes sur le cruel marché noir.
Il est évident qu’une solution à cette crise est nécessaire.
Des vies humaines sont en jeu.
En tant que biologiste et généticienne,
c’est devenu ma mission d’aider à résoudre ce problème.
Aujourd’hui, je suis optimiste en disant que nous y arriverons,
grâce à Laika.
En utilisant l’édition génétique,
il est désormais possible de créer un organe transplantable sur un humain
pouvant se développer sans risque dans des porcs.
Avant de se plonger dans cette incroyable science qui rend cela possible,
essayons de mieux comprendre ce qu’est la xénogreffe.
Il s’agit d’une transplantation d’organes d’origine animale chez des humains.
Vous vous demandez peut-être : « Pourquoi des organes de porcs ? »
Parce que les porcs possèdent des organes
avec une taille et une physiologie similaires aux organes humains.
Au cours des cinquante dernières années,
les pionniers de la transplantation se sont efforcés de donner vie au projet,
mais ils ont obtenu peu de résultats.
Pourquoi ?
Deux obstacles fondamentaux se tenaient devant eux.
Premièrement, le problème du rejet.
Quand notre système immunitaire considère un nouvel organe comme étranger,
il le rejette.
Deuxièmement, et celui-ci est spécifique aux organes de porcs,
chaque porc est porteur d’un virus bénin pour lui-même,
mais qui peut être transmis aux humains.
Il s’agit du rétrovirus endogène du porc (PERV),
et ce virus peut potentiellement causer une épidémie virale similaire au VIH.
Sans moyen efficace pour répondre à ces problèmes,
le domaine de la xénogreffe fut en suspens pendant plus de 10 ans.
Peu de progrès ont été accomplis, jusqu’à aujourd’hui.
Permettez-moi de partager avec vous comment j’en suis arrivée ici avec Laika.
Mon parcours a commencé au mont Emei en Chine.
C’est un lieu fidèlement décrit dans beaucoup de légendes,
comme « Tigre et Dragon ».
Je m’y sens chez moi.
En grandissant dans la montagne,
j’ai commencé à développer une connexion forte avec la nature.
C’est moi à l’âge de sept ans,
devant un ancien temple bouddhiste
avec un singe sur mon épaule.
Je me souviens parfaitement comment mes amis et moi
jetions des cacahuètes pour distraire les singes
pour qu’on puisse traverser et marcher dans la vallée.
J’adore la nature.
Quand il a fallu choisir un domaine d’étude,
j’ai choisi d’étudier la biologie à l’université de Pékin.
Toutefois, plus j’apprenais,
plus j’avais de questions.
Comment notre patrimoine génétique peut-il être si proche de celui des animaux
alors que nous sommes si différents ?
Comment notre système immunitaire est-il capable de combattre tant de pathogènes
tout en étant assez intelligent pour ne pas nous attaquer ?
Ce genre de questions me tourmentaient.
Je sais que cela semble bête, mais je suis une scientifique.
Après la fac, je ne voulais plus me contenter de poser des questions,
je voulais y répondre, c’est donc ce que j'ai fait.
En 2008, j’ai eu la chance d’être admise
au sein du programme de doctorat à l’université d’Harvard
et de travailler avec le Dr George Church.
En travaillant dans son laboratoire,
j’ai commencé à apprendre et à tester la composition génétique des mammifères.
Parmi toutes les expériences,
une en particulier m’a rapprochée de Laika.
En 2013, mes collègues et moi-même avons effectué des changements
sur une cellule humaine, en utilisant un outil que vous connaissez peut-être
appelé CRISPR.
Nous étions l’un des deux premiers groupes à rapporter avec succès l’utilisation
d’un tel instrument pour changer notre ADN.
C’était un grand moment pour la découverte scientifique.
L’outil de manipulation génétique CRISPR a deux composants.
Un ciseau nommé l’enzyme CRISPR
et ce qu’on appelle un ARN guide.
Imaginez des ciseaux génétiques avec un microscope.
Le microscope est l’ARN guide,
qui amène les ciseaux où nous voulons qu’ils coupent
et qui dit : « C’est ici. »
Et l’enzyme CRISPR coupe et répare l’ADN comme nous le souhaitons.
Peu après avoir annoncé notre étude,
des médecins du Mass General Hospital furent intrigués
par les applications médicales de nos recherches.
Ils nous ont contactés,
et ensemble, nous avons commencé à voir le potentiel d’utiliser CRISPR
pour résoudre la pénurie d’organes.
Comment faisons-nous ça ?
C’est très simple, et à la fois très complexe.
Nous avons commencé par modifier la cellule d’un porc
afin de le rendre exempt de virus
et compatible avec le système immunitaire humain.
Le noyau de cette cellule est ensuite implanté dans un œuf de porc
pour qu’il se divise en un embryon.
L’embryon résultant est ensuite placé dans l’utérus d’une mère porteuse
et deviendra un porcelet.
Cela ressemble beaucoup au processus de clonage.
Le porcelet porte ainsi des organes dont la constitution génétique
ne devrait pas être rejetée par le système immunitaire humain.
En 2015, notre équipe s’est attaquée au problème de la transmission virale.
Nous voulions enlever les 62 copies du virus PERV
du génome du porc,
mais à l’époque, c’était presque mission impossible.
Même avec CRISPR,
nous ne pouvions faire qu’une ou deux modifications dans une cellule.
Le nombre record de modifications que nous pouvions effectuer
dans une cellule donnée n’était que de 5.
Nous avons dû augmenter le débit de dix fois pour atteindre cet objectif.
Avec une conception très soignée et des centaines d’essais,
nous avons réussi à éliminer tout le virus,
et à battre le record.
Plus important encore,
nos études ont montré que nous pouvions éliminer la possibilité
que ce virus dangereux soit transmis à l’homme.
L’année dernière, grâce à une cellule modifiée et la technologie de clonage,
notre startup, eGenesis, a produit Laika,
le premier porc de son genre, né sans PERV.
(Applaudissements)
Laika représente la première étape cruciale
dans l’établissement d’une xénotransplantation sans danger.
C’est également une plateforme
sur laquelle nous pourrons faire d’autres modifications génétiques
pour résoudre le problème de l’immunologie.
Depuis, nous avons créé plus de 30 porcs sans PERV,
et ils sont probablement les animaux génomodifiés les plus avancés
sur Terre.
Nous l’avons appelé Laika en l’honneur du chien soviétique
qui fut le premier animal à orbiter autour de la Terre.
Nous espérons que Laika et ses frères et sœurs
pourront nous mener vers une nouvelle frontière
de la science et de la médecine.
Imaginez un monde où les patients souffrant d’insuffisance hépatique
pourraient être sauvés grâce à un nouveau foie
sans devoir attendre un don
ou la mort d’un autre être humain.
Imaginez un monde où les personnes atteintes de diabète
n’auraient plus besoin d’insuline après chaque repas,
car nous pourrions leur fournir de bonnes cellules pancréatiques
qui pourront produire de l’insuline par leurs propres moyens.
Et imaginez un monde où les patients souffrant d’insuffisance rénale
ne seraient plus confrontés au fardeau de la dialyse.
Nous nous efforçons de créer ce monde,
un monde sans pénurie d’organes.
Nous avons enfin l’outil pour résoudre le problème
que nous n’aurions jamais pu aborder auparavant,
et Laika n’est que le début de notre voyage.
Nous devons être très humbles face à la nature,
parce qu’il y a beaucoup de problèmes à traiter,
y compris l’immunologie
et des choses que nous ne pouvons pas anticiper pour l’instant.
Cependant, il est de notre responsabilité de traduire la science de pointe
en traitements pour sauver la vie de tous les patients qui attendent.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Luhan, c’est un travail extraordinaire.
Venez.
Donc quelles sont les prochaines étapes ? Vous vous êtes débarrassée du virus.
Les prochaines étapes consistent à parvenir à ce qu’un corps humain
ne rejette plus une greffe.
Qu’est-ce que cela implique ?
Luhan Yang : C’est un processus très compliqué.
Nous devons donc éliminer l’antigène des porcs.
De plus, nous pouvons en apprendre beaucoup du cancer.
Comment le cancer peut-il envahir ou contourner notre système immunitaire ?
Nous pourrions utiliser la ruse du cancer
et l’appliquer sur un organe de porc
pour tromper notre système immunitaire afin qu’il n’attaque pas l’organe.
CA : Quand estimez-vous, quand espérez-vous
que la première greffe réussisse ?
LY : Il serait irresponsable de ma part de vous donner une date.
CA : Nous sommes à TED. Nous sommes toujours irresponsables.
LY : Mais nous travaillons jour et nuit pour que cela marche pour les patients.
CA : Donc vous ne pouvez pas dire si cela peut se réaliser dans une décennie
ou dans cinq ans ?
LY : Nous espérons que cela se produira d’ici une décennie.
(Rires)
CA : Il y a beaucoup de gens ici qui seraient très enthousiastes,
le potentiel est extraordinaire.
Il y a d’autres personnes ici qui diraient :
« Ce cochon est trop mignon.
Les humains ne devraient pas exploiter quelque chose d’aussi mignon
pour notre bénéfice. »
Avez-vous une réponse à cela ?
LY : Oui, bien sûr.
Imaginez qu’un cochon puisse sauver la vie de huit personnes.
De plus, comme pour un don humain,
si nous ne retirons qu’un seul rein, le porc continuera de vivre,
nous sommes donc très attentifs aux problèmes,
mais je pense que notre objectif est de répondre
aux besoins médicaux insatisfaisants pour ces patients et leur famille.
CA : Et personne ne peut vous dire ça s’il mange du bacon, n’est-ce pas ?
LY : C’est un bon argument.
(Rires)
CA : Luhan, merci beaucoup. LY : Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)